So now, I'd like to
discuss App Engine
Architecture and Services.
So before I get started, I'd
like to warn you one thing.
Google App Engine can be
dangerous for developers
because it can change
your life.
I found that I no longer was
interested in ordinary,
traditional web application
technology anymore.
After the App Engine project, I
had to build another typical
MySQL kind of web server
with applications.
And I was so tired
of doing that.
So this job is very dangerous
and will change the way you
approach web application
development.
In this lesson, I'd like to
discuss about three things.
One is the scalability and
reliability that's provided by
Google App Engine.
And I'd like to compare that
between the traditional way of
designing web applications and
the App Engine design.
I'd also like to discuss two
major components that are
running inside the
App Engine stack.
One is the Front End and how
the Front End works.
And another is the App Server
and how it works.
The first topic, "Designing for
Scale and Reliability." So
here's an excellent example of
an App Engine application
that's called Real time
Earthquake Monitor.
And it's built by the NIED,
developed by the
public sector in Japan.
This is the actual
app running.
You can see that there are many
blinking dots, blue dots
or green dots, on the
map of Japan.
Each dot represents the
acceleration of the ground
surface right now in Japan.
So if you're having an
earthquake right now, you'll
be seeing yellow or red dots
will be spreading out all over
that region.
And I have another demonstration
that shows you
how it worked in the 3/11
disaster we had last year.
So you'll be able to see red and
yellow dots spreading out
from the northern
part of Japan.
Yes, that's what happened on
the 3/11 disaster we had.
So let's discuss how the
app is designed for
this kind of system.
So this system is built with the
App Engine as well as the
data center which is
hosted by the NIED.
It has many sensors on
the surface of the
ground all over Japan.
And all the metrics will be
collected by them at the data
centers for us where they can
create an image file.
They ping and publish it in the
Google App Engine every
one second.
And then the client, the
browsers, the users, are
polling that image every
two seconds.
So that means at peak rate,
since there are about 20,000
people, the App Engine will be
getting about 10,000 requests
per second at peak.
So what are the important
requirements for this app?
We can summarize these as
scalability, reliability, and
cost efficiency.
So scalability because this site
will be getting a spike
of traffic in the event
of the earthquake.
So it has to provide more
scalability than
your ordinary website.
And also, it has to provide
these so high of a reliability
because the people will be using
this site only when they
have the disaster.
If you're connecting to this
site and it's down because of
the disaster, then it doesn't
mean anything.
And also, it has to be more
efficient on cost.
If you're preparing for the old
hardware resources that
will be required to provide the
scalability, then it means
that almost all the
time that hardware
resource will be resting.
Nobody's connecting
using that.
So you have to be scalable
enough to provide enough
server resources, but you don't
have that much money to
buy all the hardware
resources itself.
So how do we design a web
service like that that's
scalable and reliable?
This is how you do it in a
traditional way of web
application design.
Because it should be reliable
and scalable, you may have
multiple instances
of Apache with a
server or MySQL instances.
But if you have a single
hardware failure on the
server, that should failover
instantly.
It means you also have to be
prepared for load balances or
reverse proxies.
And we'd need to buy two
or three of them.
And if you have a traffic spike,
then the load should be
balanced among the multiple
instances of the server.
And if you are handling big
data and if it's growing
rapidly, then it means you have
to have multiple MySQL.
And you have to design a
sharded MySQL instance.
And this can be very hard.
If you have experience
developing this, then you know
you have to configure
and test everything,
every possible pattern.
What if you have a failure
on the reverse proxy?
What if you have multiple
failures on your web service?
You have to configure
and test them all.
And don't forget that you have
to hire the people who have
this experience.
It all costs so much.
So App Engine provides them all,
allows you to build that
kind of cluster and encapsulate
it in an App
Engine application,
all running on
Google's data centers.
You don't need to administer
that anymore, like if you have
a hardware failure on one
server, your application will
not stop at all.
If you have a traffic spike, the
app service automatically
will add more instances on
demand based on the daily
number of the request.
If you're having so much big
data that it's growing
rapidly, automatically,
Datastores will be splitting
your data into multiple shards
of Datastore servers.
And you can start using
App Engine without
any money up front.
You don't need to hire expensive
administrators to
operate this massive cluster.
After migrating onto App Engine,
you don't have to have
a dedicated experienced Linux
administrator anymore.
And let them focus on
the more business
essential thing to do.
To appreciate this App Engine
design more fully, you have to
understand what is the
design goal behind
the App Engine stack.
It's not just the hosting
environment.
And it's not just
the data center.
Google App Engine encourages
you to use Google's best
practices to design
your applications.
So if you have experience in
producing a project that is
using App Engine, you may have
noticed that there are certain
restrictions, rules, and
practices to follow.
But these are important best
practices to make your
application design in the
Googly way; scalable and
reliable, like the
non-relational data model.
When you're using Datastore--
not Cloud SQL or MySQL
instances--
you have to design your data
model that can be sharded.
And sometimes, you may want to
use the techniques, like in
data normalization.
That may sound like a downside,
but if you're an
experienced web application
developer, you probably
realize that this is actually
a best practice to make any
scalable and reliable website.
So the most important point is
that you have to make your
application portable
and fine-grained.
By designing your application
in this way, you can use the
whole data center
as the computer.
You are not writing your code on
a specific server anymore.
You are writing code for the
data center or the group of
data centers.
You may notice when you're
using these APIs, like
Datastore APIs or Memcache with
App Engine, that these
APIs are abstracting a whole
bunch of data centers.
It's not just an API running
on a single server.
So in that way, you can utilize
the server resources
at a very high utilization
rate.
That ultimately means you get
significantly lower Total Cost
of Ownership.
You can leverage the scale of
economy because your App
Engine is sharing the exactly
the same Google infrastructure
that's used by other Google
services, such as Google
Search or Maps.
Google's SREs or site
reliability engineers will be
watching your systems 24 by 7.
And actually, Google SREs are
one of the premium roles in
Google's entire company.
It's very hard to hire
these kind of people.
So to utilize and realize
benefits--
getting benefits from those
goals are design principles
behind the App Engine stack--
you have to understand how
things are working inside the
Google App Engine stack.
Now, I'd like to go deeper and
dive into the two major
components.
One is the Front End.
And the other is
the App Server.
These parts, right here.
So now, to the second topic,
"How the Front End works."
Actually, I really like this
diagram because it tells so
much to me about what's
happening inside the App
Engine stack.
So we'll refer back to it
throughout this lesson.
What benefits would the
Front End provide?
So here, you have the actual
graph that I have taken from
the Earthquake Real time
Monitor applications.
And you can see that the number
of requests per second
on the site is getting most of
the time, it's around 1,000
requests per second if
you're not having an
earthquake or event.
So it's still a very big
number of requests.
And you can see the blue line.
This is actually the number
of requests routed to the
application instance.
It's like 1/10 or 1/12.
There's a huge difference.
And it means that you don't
have to pay for this
difference.
You can just pay for
the blue request.
So how do they do that?
Earthquake site broadcasts the
image to thousands of users
without handling all the
requests by the app.
How can you do that?
So the secret is in
the Front End.
In the Front End component,
there are actually two
different components.
One is called the Google
Front End.
And another thing is called
the App Engine Front End.
And Google Front End resides
in a data center which is
closest to the user.
So if you have global users,
then all the data centers
worldwide we have in each
region will be accepting
requests from those users
because we have so many close
relationship pairings--
our relationship with
the major ISPs--
most of the requests users will
be sending to us will be
accepted, received by the
closest data center.
And Google's Front
End is running
inside that data center.
And that's shared by most of
the other Google services,
like Google Search
or Google Maps.
And it also has the edge
caching capabilities.
This is the key technology.
And afterwards, because it's
received by Google, that
request will be routed to other
data centers that's
running the actual App
Engine services.
We have Google's fibre
backbone, so it
will be routed fast.
And that second data center is
running another Front End
called our App Engine Front End
that will provide the load
balancing among the multiple
instances of the app servers
as well as the static servers.
So here, the key
points are edge
caching and load balancing.
So how do you enable the
edge caching feature?
There are two ways of
using edge caching.
One is setting the cache-control
header on your
HTTP request.
Then another one is using the
Static content configuration.
You can just set these kinds
of headers and set the
expiration period, like whatever
amount you want, to
tell Google's Front End
to cache the content.
And also, there's another
way that you can
define a Static content.
So if you have a static HTML
file or an image file on your
applications, those are all
served by the App Server, from
an App Server to the browsers.
So it costs you.
Instead, you can define a Static
content, like this, in
the configuration file so that
all the content will be served
by the static servers.
So the last topic is, "How the
App Server works." Now, let's
look at the App Server
in detail.
What if the App Server can
dynamically increase the
number of your app instances
based on the load you get?
And the App Engine developer
needs to know how you can
control it and get the best
cost-performance efficiency.
The App Server is our server
that provides our runtime
environment for your application
instances.
Just like the virtual machines,
like when you're
deploying a new application on
App Engine, the App Master
will initially ask App Servers
to host that particular
application.
And if your application is
getting many requests from
users, then the App Master
directs App Servers to have
more application instances
to scale out.
And also, App Master tells the
App Engine Front End the
location of the App
Server where your
application is running.
So the App Master orchestrates
the whole load balancing or
scaling out; whereas, the App
Server provides runtime
environment for the application
instance.
Application instances in App
Engine is very similar to
virtual machines.
And also, just like in virtual
machines, has a dedicated
memory for your application.
But the biggest difference
is it's fully managed.
You don't have to bear the
burden of managing the whole
operating system or
application stack.
You don't have to care about
what version of the device
driver you're using or what
kind of security patches
you've applied to the OS or what
versions of the libraries
or application services
you're using.
You don't have to queue
them all up.
Everything's taken care
of by Google.
So that's the huge difference.
And also importantly, if you're
running always inside
the virtual machine, there is
a certain big overhead for
that because you're running
different OS images on
different virtual machine
instances.
It is a certain overhead, like
it can be an overhead in terms
of the CPU hours, for example.
So application instances
in App Engine
doesn't have that overhead.
And also, it's fully managed.
You have to understand there
are two different types of
application instances.
One is a Frontend instance.
And another is a Backend
instance.
In Frontend instance, it's
suitable for processing
short-lived requests, like when
you click a button on
your web application.
And your request should be
handled within a few seconds.
Those kinds of requests
should be handled by
the Frontend, generally.
Instead Backends should be used
for long-lived requests,
like batch processing,
that should be
running during the night.
Or if the process would take 10
minutes or 10's of minutes.
And Frontend instances will be
dynamically created and deleted.
It means you can minimize the
costs of the CPU hours where
the Backend instances
will be statically--
not totally statically.
There are some dynamic
characteristics of the Backend
instance, too.
But it can be a higher cost
value Frontend instance.
Frontend instances, as you
may know, there's a big
limitation--
the 60-second limitation
on that.
So you have to design your
systems to process everything,
to process every request
within 60 seconds.
And also, you want to make
your application in a
stateless design; whereas, the
Backend instance, there's no
limit for a response time.
So you can spend like
10's of minutes to
handle a single request.
And you can rely on
the statefulness
of the server instance.
But currently, we are having the
separation between them.
And I'd like to show you how the
Frontend instance will be
scaling out.
App Engine are watching the
status of the Pending Requests
Queues that's held by each
application instance.
Each application instance has
a queue that will be holding
the request from the users.
So if you're getting a spike
of traffic, that means the
queue will be filled up
with many requests.
In that case, the App Engine
detects it and is trying to
add more and more Frontend
instances.
Once you have processed all the
requests from the queue,
then App Engine tries to reduce
the number of Frontend
instances--
so dynamically scaling
out and scaling in.
And the important thing to
notice is that there are two
important parameters.
One is the Pending Latency.
And the other is
Idle Instances.
What is Pending Latency?
Pending Latency is the time
to hold the largest in the
pending queue before creating
a new instance.
It means if you are setting a
very short time period to
these parameters, then App
Engine will be creating more
and more instances instantly
without waiting for a certain
amount of time.
If you're setting this amount to
be a very big amount, like
15 seconds, then your
application can respond slowly.
Plus, you can save your cost
for the instance hours.
So you can have a balance
between the trade-offs,
between the cost and
the responsiveness.
Also, there's another important
parameter called
Idle Instances, which is the
number of the instances you
will be having even if your
application is not getting any
requests from users.
If you set this number to
something, like 10 instances,
10 idle instances, then it means
even if you're getting
no requests from users, there
will be 10 application
instances running
all the time.
It will cost you higher, but it
can respond to the sudden
spike of traffic much
more quickly.
How long will it take for
creating a new instance?
Whenever a server tries to
create a new application
instance, the App Server will
actually be reading the .class
file or the .py file of the
application loading it, so the
instance can do the
initialization.
Normally, it would be
under one second.
But if you're using so many
libraries throughout, then
sometimes, like using the Spring
Framework for example,
it sometimes takes 30 seconds
or 60 seconds.
And you'll be seeing exceptions
in that case.
So every App Engine developer
has to be careful about the
loading request and what latency
you will get when your
application will be
instantiated.
Key Takeaways.
App Engine encapsulates all
the cost and the effort to
build scalable and available
applications on its cluster.
It's not just a hosting
platform.
It's a platform that encourages
users to design
your system in Google's best
practices for scalability and
reliability.
The Front End provides the Edge
Caching and Load Balancing.
These are very important
technologies to utilize.
And the App Server controls
the scalability of the
Frontend instance and the
Backend instances.
Pending Latencies and Idle
Instances are key parameters
to use for controlling
that behavior.